basically everything about valorent
feels worse than cs except the hit rag
man
favorite annual cs event outside of the
majors i feel like you could say cattle
or you could say cologne but i think
honestly for me it's summit man maybe
it's because i come from dota but like
to me i've just always really really
really loved the summit events for
anything you know for cs for dota for
smash
this one
god what is your most wanted skin in cs
right now i really want a black pearl i
just think they're really cool i think
um bayonets are sick and it's the only
finish that i don't have right now if
you could take one thing from valorant
and add it to cs what would it be i have
two the actual
player outlines the second thing is
smaller and that's
if you buy something you should be able
to sell it